E aí
[Música]
Oi boa tarde em todo mundo quando vindo
aqui eu sou a Gabriela Augusto e eu
gostaria de começar com uma pergunta
e vocês já sentiram medo de na padaria
e vocês já sentiram Medo de ao
restaurante
Olá tudo bem com isso porque esse receio
infelizmente faz parte do meu cotidiano
Ah e por que isso acontece
e eu poderia passar a tarde toda
contando histórias falando de momentos
onde ia sofrer algum tipo de violência
mas eu vou contar um caso específico que
aconteceu comigo
é mas antes de contar sobre essa
situação é uma informação extra para
vocês
e como vocês já devem ter percebido eu
sou uma mulher criança e além de mulher
trans Eu também sou casada com uma outra
mulher
e eu digo isso tô contando aqui para
vocês porque são fácil está casada com
outra mulher ainda causa bastante
estranhamento nas pessoas ainda me
perguntam Gabriela mas como assim você
virou mulher inadequada usar esse termo
mas como assim você virou mulher e você
gosta de mulheres
e enfim pessoas trans mulheres trans
lésbicas Existe ponto e voltando a a
minha história e o fui comemorar o
aniversário da minha esposa
E era uma sexta-feira à noite nós fomos
em uma festa bastante famosa de São
Paulo não vou falar o nome da festa e
assim eu e minha esposa chegamos lá e
como a fila de revista feminina
eu esperei minha vez em quando a
segurança foi me avistar Ela me
perguntou se eu era mulher
e eu livrei ela e disse que sim mulher
E aí nesse momento ela virou para mim e
falou
e Então me prova
E aí
e eu peguei um pouco pensei falei para
ela moça você acha que isso é realmente
necessário
quem sabe porque nos documentos ainda
não estão retificados eu não sei se eu
vou conseguir provar é isso para você da
forma se você deseja Mas só se você acha
que realmente né cara porque ele parece
que você só deve olhar talvez a minha
bolsa você nem precisa encostar em mim
sabe e a moça falou não Regras São
Regras eu não posso te revistar você tem
que ir para fila masculina
e eu não deveria ter feito isso mas eu
fui eu fui para flangeamento masculino e
isso por si só já foi uma situação
bastante humilhante
e assim não sei se vocês têm facilidade
para imaginar a cena você está noite
essa grande festa assim havia centenas
de pessoas lá esperando sua vez para ser
resultados e as pessoas começaram
apontar e dar risada sabe eu vi pessoas
falando olha só o t****** tá querendo
enganar os seguranças da festa
Ah e assim não acabou por aí nesse dia
eu fui para a fila de revista masculina
stre minha vez e quando o segurança foi
meditar e disse que não sabe o que fazer
e ele falou que precisava falar com o
coordenador precisava ver qual que era o
procedimento sabe
ou vocês preferem
É sim olha só tenho que imaginar a
situação você saiu uma sexta à noite com
alguém que você ama para se divertir
assim nós achamos que seriam um momento
que a gente teria uma boa lembrança
seria Enfim uma noite de comemoração mas
não uma história triste que eu tô
comprando aqui pra vocês e assim eu faço
cotidianamente por situações parecidas
com essa assim eu acabei me tornando
talvez posso usar o creme calejada mas
nessa noite
é a minha esposa ela ela chorou bastante
sabe
e assim foi uma situação bastante
milhões para nós e assim durante muito
tempo que eu me culpei por isso não só
por essa situação específica mas por tá
fazendo quem eu amo sofrer em casa minha
esposa mas também minha mãe meus
familiares eu me culpei durante muito
tem
é por tudo isso que tava com você mas
quando um pouco mais para pensar a
respeito eu cheguei à conclusão de que a
culpa não era de ninguém
e nesse caso um exemplo dessa festa eu
culpa de empresa
e em minha opinião as empresas têm o
dever de concientizar os seus
colaboradores de levar o conhecimento
sobre a diversidade e não só pensando na
questão trans pensando também no combate
ao racismo no combate ao assédio no
combate a outros tipos de preconceitos e
viés pensando uma pessoa com deficiência
presente
o e Vejam só esse momento dessa festa
foi lá para 2016 eu chegando à conclusão
de que as empresas tinham essa
responsabilidade de promover discussões
nas adversidades que que eu fiz
e eu desenvolvi o materialzinho de
concentração impresso o livro de bolso
de 16 partes que ele trazia não só os
conceitos mais essenciais sobre a
questão trans mais trazia também outros
conceitos relacionados a combate ao
racismo ao combate à Sérgio enfim
diversidade uma abordagem mais geral e o
que que eu fiz com esse material esse
livro é eu saí fui de porta em porta nas
empresas eles realmente não sei se vocês
conhecem São Paulo a Palmas eu fui
Principalmente nos bairros Pinheiros
Vila Madalena eu fui em restaurantes eu
fui em Coworking em seu fui em Academias
bares e eu ficava para conversar com os
donos com as donas procurava entender
qualquer
em relação à abordagem eles com
diversidade já tinham tido algum caso de
assédio como que eles tinham lidado com
essas situações e assim esse Foi um
momento de grande aprendizado para mim
poderia mais uma vez passar a tarde toda
aqui contando tanto coisas boas quando
coisas ruins que houve dessas esses
donos e donas presas mas eu vi algo com
bastante frequência
e eu vi desse donos dessas horas de
empresas que Gabriela como que eu vou
falar de diversidade com os meus
colaboradores
um pouco
Oi e eu posso desenvolver essa discussão
promover discussão sobre a diversidade
de forma que eles estejam abertos ao vir
fazer algo a respeito
é uma coisa que eu disse para ele
bom é que assim por mais que nós é o seu
dono entender sobre a questão três antes
de ter sim sim
a gente pode se colocar uma ideia que é
mais Universal pé do respeito
e por mais que haja um pessoas que não
entendam a questão da identidade de
gênero
e quando a gente fala de respeito é
difícil encontrar alguém que discorde
this
G1
E aí
Ah e assim havendo do valor da
diversidade e tal tango nesse conceito
mais Universal que o conceito de
respeito a gente também precisa entender
se para a respeitar a gente precisa
conhecer
se você tem informações sabe porque
muitas vezes a pessoa Pisa Na Bola por
exemplo uso de pronome não sei se vocês
têm certa familiaridade com essas
discussões mas assim não se fala ou
travesti certo é a travesti por ser
sempre uma figura feminina é muitas
vezes as pessoas é ruim conceitos mais
básicos por desconhecimento e não por
maldade e
bom então assim se a gente se pauta na
ideia do respeito a gente precisa tentar
também em como multiplicar essas
informações e esses conhecimentos aí
quem entra uma outra ideia o papel do
aliado
a gente não precisa ser negro ou Negro
para ser um aliado na luta contra o
racismo a gente não precisa ser LGBT
para ser uma olhada uma olhada na luta
contra a gente de ter comido todos nós
todos nós também temos condições de
faltar essas discussões nas nossas
empresas nas nossas organizações
e nós temos um papel de multiplicadores
pago desconhecimento um exemplo que eu
dei aqui sobre a travesti a próxima vez
que vocês ouvirem alguém falando outra
vestir Talvez seja uma ideia com a
Fulano Não é bem assim sabe eu tive uma
palestra e me falaram que é muito
correto usar o termo a travesti é
importante que a gente entende o nosso
papel nessa jornada é algo mais de gás
mais inclusive Pensando que nós é
podemos ser multiplicadores desse
conhecimento e assim
é uma coisa que importantíssimo também
que a gente entenda ensinou esse papel
de multiplicador hoje enfim promover
essas opções é que quando nós estamos
falando de diversidade a gente tem que
entender isso como uma rosca com o
processo também não é do dia para noite
e que as nossas organizações vamos se
tornar lugares livres de preconceito
livre já Sérgio livre de qualquer tipo
de viagem intolerância não é não é do
dia para noite não vai ser em um card
aqui também de 18 minutos que a gente
vai sair daqui totalmente desconstruído
não a gente precisa entender essa luta
contra preconceito e outro tipo de
violência como um processo
e é ninguém conversar sim para finalizar
aqui a grande mensagem que eu te deixar
aqui para vocês é que se cada um de nós
se nós fizermos a nossa parte sendo
pessoas e multiplicam esse conhecimento
cada um fizer um pouquinho eu tenho
certeza que a gente vai construir sim o
mundo mais justo e menos desigual Muito
obrigado
E aí